i'm going to rent a car today i'm kind
of terrified
i've never driven here before i just
thought it would make it easier uh for
me and marcia to set up a lot of things
to have a car usually when you're in
japan you're like there's a couple
foreigners in there like tourists but
i'm the only one
there's no tourist whatsoever
i feel very out of place
[Applause]
i think that's the one
it's so ugly
i got the car i'm so scared i'm
terrified
he did not speak english very well and i
speak
no japanese but we managed to get by
he helped me set up the
navigation it's not a long ride so i
should be fine but
i am a little scared
i'm like
do i drive on the left side or the right
side i can't remember oh god i did it
holy [ __ ] i'm so happy
that was so fun i don't know i was so
nervous and now that i've done it i feel
amazing i'm so glad that was so cool the
roads are so pretty nothing like driving
in london
oh i'm so happy
definitely worth it it's the
ugliest car i've ever seen but uh i'm
[ __ ] thrilled that's great i've been
practicing japanese but i don't know
anything but i know we know i knew
enough to understand him and i made it
so much easier so i'm so glad
i've done that but i definitely need to
learn more holy [ __ ]
i did it
killed
yeah you should it's the worst car ever
made yeah
yeah that's our car
for a month
you can't take off without the keys
we're going on a car ride it's so fun to
drive here
feels like i have my driver license at
18 again
but i got my buddy with me yeah
we're going to
we've been there once before there's so
much to look at when i'm driving and i'm
trying to like focus on not hitting
people
maya's killing it
look at you
cute
okay so cut to us like three years ago
we went to this temple and we left one
of our cats and we wrote our names on it
so obviously we gotta see if we're still
there
come on
come on
we uh we left the line and it's okay to
bring dogs
as long as they don't go
inside even though this is a cat temple
is this appropriate no think about it
this is insane
i had forgotten
what do you think maya
is it cool
i guess they knew we brought dogs
it's closed down
but i don't think we're gonna find it
along here so
maybe next time
[Music]
definitely recommend checking out
once they reopen
so
pretty spots faces on everything
i did not see it
look at this tower of cardboard
oh my goodness recycling is very
different here
i mean it's still the same at the end of
it but we missed last week's collection
day so
we just collected so much and they want
you to tie it all up which to be honest
i find very satisfying like just holding
it like
i don't know if you have to do this
but like milk cartridges you're supposed
to wash them and let them dry we gotta
learn these things so yeah that's a lot
of cardboard i'm sorry whoever has to
collect that
today
i'm going to see uh joey
the anime man and we're going to check
out some arcades
he asked me what the first thing i want
to do is so you got to check out the
arcades i'm very excited
joey the mad lad starts off with two
[ __ ] strikes
oh
okay all right
what a form
oh you have to go for a stride
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
my [ __ ] god
[Applause]
well yeah dude
let's [ __ ] go
all right so joey won the first one but
i won the real challenge
[Music]
the photocopy
where's your reward joey
how how does that work no no
i'm going in on my own our free reward
might say don't get jealous
oh
how does it look
[Music]
oh god
one last one
[Music]
i lost one
[Music]
yes
sorry i just went for it
[Music]
oh
they're so tiny
remember all these things that we did
joey
[Music]
that was super fun
kind of sensory overload i'm not really
used to this
[Music]
keep shooting
keep going
[Music]
come on
i don't know what's happening
[Music]
[Music]
come on joey don't [ __ ] it
oh no no no
no
he can't die he's the protagonist
we got 413 though holy
go [ __ ] on
come on ball come on come on
[Music]
come on
keep going
oh
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
we got it no
wait what happened i think we missed it
all of that for nothing
today we're going to
register ourselves at the town hall
and we have to register our dogs as well
but i have a feeling this will be kind
of difficult
because we don't speak japanese this is
insane
i think this is it
is that the building
i'm squeezing every inch of my japanese
out to make this work
we didn't bring our marriage certificate
and they wanted it to register as a
couple
so technically like we google online
what you need and it doesn't say but
we're going to go to 7-eleven to try and
print it because we have it we just
didn't have a physical copy of it but uh
they were super helpful otherwise uh we
can't complain there it is
the rule of japan
a 7-eleven is always nearby
we didn't
we're officially registered in japan it
took a a long time
but you know what it didn't even matter
they were so nice and so helpful
everyone is just so sweet it was just
amazing i'm so impressed how they run
everything even the dogs get registered
which is great
so we're officially japanese
right wow
that's not how that works the guy said
congratulations when we left though this
is so sweet
oh yeah look what we got here
she loves it
[Laughter]
now we're a real family
[Laughter]
do you like it maya
i feel like anywhere else we would feel
silly right now but since we're in japan
edgar still has to walk
also for the record maya is almost 17
years old
so she definitely deserves it you
deserve some of them too yes
he was getting tired
i'm an old man as well
all right guys good night
faster mom
faster
how do i look
great how do they work
you having fun
we got a private jet for you
we got this thing for you what else do
you want
are you okay in there
i think she likes it in a weird way
just wow but look at what a baby
i robbed japan guys it's so good over
here
today we're in omotesando i'm not used
to seeing all the big buildings yet
this is not even that big but yeah i
think the rainy season is about to start
so that's why
today's a really rainy day i hope i can
buy some clothes i'm very outdated
wardrobe
[Music]
me
[Music]
damn
it is empty today
it's almost like everyone has a job or
something
got some nice uh second-hand shop stuff
i can't believe how few people there are
here it's usually smack full
i want to check out some japanese brands
there's neighborhood around the corner
we're about to go on the worst street
ever
for the business at least takashi the
street
i guess since it's not busy it's not
that bad yeah usually it's smack packed
here here's one of my favorite shops
i don't know what it's called but it
looks cool
[Music]
oh
marxist faith in humanity was restored
because
she bought two of these what are they
called
kokodama
they're beautiful we used to have one in
the uk
so cute
what do you think again
that one's beautiful
i want one in my office okay so might
say i just showed me the third one and
he was so nice he'd noticed that you
liked it sir he gave it for free
it was very generous he just noticed
that you liked it and was like present
he didn't have to do that that was so
nice
some people are just nice
as he's getting emotional over a
kokodama that was gifted
it's finally here
yes
oh
fresh
yeah
oh
yes
today
we're going to check out some cars
they got these um retro toyotas i think
i think they're called like renoka they
look really good i'm curious to see them
[Music]
wow
[Music]
they're so cool
we're gonna
test drive the fj so he was telling me
about the
black one
which is called hachimaru i kind of got
really interested in it
but i know it's way too big
which car do you think i get
i like the hachimara
so big and black like me
i'm back
i'm supposed to
i was supposed to go to tesla and uh as
well today i didn't
it took a lot longer
than i expected so i never i rescheduled
for another day
i still want to check them out
i still really like this car like
it looks good
i'm worried that it's too big then
there's this one
the fj that both me and marty likes
which i think will look really good
and they can change parts on it too but
i love this one
it's so pretty what should i do leave a
comment
anyway i'm going out to see connor and
joy now